it's been a journey to say the least for
Cameron wake one of the top players in
the National Football League five-time
Pro Bowler from the Dolphins back here
on the Rich Eisen show how are you doing
Cameron I'm doing great thanks Adam II
so I guess this is technically your 11th
season playing professional football how
are you different now than you were back
when you did come off the campus from
central Pennsylvania oh the great thing
is I'm not much different
obviously footballs not a perfect
science I was one of those guys I got
got overlooked but uh and I'm glad the
organization Miami Dolphins found me and
I've been here for you know quite a
while and I've enjoyed every minute of
it I mean it's a game change you know
technically oh I checked positions
that's about all you know I was also
kind of a traditional stand-up
linebacker Sam linebacker when I played
at Penn State but you know when I went
to Canada BC Lions I put my head in the
ground and I was a you know a four three
defensive end and that's what we play
here and Oh down in Miami I'm that
traditional defensive end not probably
inside a statute but in mindset and
skillsets so you know again game is
football football game to the
quarterback getting to the quarterback
draw to where you do it and you know
I've been I've been blessed fun alone
here Miami doing that the fact that you
went to ball up to the BC Lions you went
to Canada do you wear that as a chip on
your shoulder every day um it has a lot
of different meanings a lot of different
words people call it different things
chip humble um you know blessing I mean
it's been called a lot of things but it
is something you know the journey you
know creates a different mentality a
different mindset you know and even more
than that I was actually out of football
you know I worked a regular nine-to-five
I was in the quote unquote
real world now getting up in the morning
going through traffic putting on a suit
and tie doing all those things and it
gives you a different appreciation of
being able to play the game that you
love and do what I do and you know every
day I use those things that can shift as
you call it that experience those you
know feel the fire and then allow me to
go out there and and
play with passion and you have to be
able to do that to be successful one is
we got the position what job did you
have camera what what job did you have I
was a mortgage broker and also a
personal trainer
later on after I kind of want to get
back in the athletic world get back in
the shade make sure I was ready when my
numberless cause hopefully when my
number was called and so we had a person
trained allowed me to work out and you
know get a little bit of you know cash
on the side to obviously live life so
you know I was kind of doing two birds
one stone and then additional eyes came
calling out with physically I was ready
so basically Cameron wake you you know
how to sack the quarterback stay in
shape and you can refinance a mortgage
it should you choose I can do it or I
can do it all the more you can do it
more about if you have a country I like
it
alright let's talk about your current
situation with the Miami Dolphins
Cameron obviously you cannot control
what goes on on the other side of the
ball what is it like to be ready for a
season have the quarterback that you've
known for the past few years come back
and ready to believe in him and be led
by Ryan Tannehill and all of a sudden
now it's Jay Cutler in that position
what is that like oh well it's a bit of
an adjustment I mean I think regardless
of wood you know situation or what
position you're talking about in this
league it's a violent violent sport it's
not a contact sport collision sport and
you know more often than not you're
going to have injuries you know I've
never been on a team that has made it
through without someone you know being
put down and having somebody else come
take their place it's a little different
obviously a quarterback but you kind of
have to address it the same way you do
anywhere else you you know obviously you
don't want anybody to get hurt you don't
want anybody to have injuries it's part
of the game and then you have to kind of
do the next man up mentality and the
football rosters are built so that
obviously you have the best player as
you probably can that if something
happens whether it's an actual injury or
shoelace or a wardrobe malfunction
whatever it is the next guy that goes in
you expect them to play at a high level
expecting to be able to fill those shoes
of
was the geyser spawner that was out and
really the expectations are the same so
you know I don't think that's any
different I can speak Brendan what I'm
talking about Santa Hill and Cutler to
say I know that he knows that there's
expectations on him to fill the shoes
that Ryan had a big shoes and obviously
you've been playing very well and his
last few games he played he's let this
seem to be obviously getting to the
playoffs last year and we wouldn't
expect anything less from whoever's and
that's in that next pot coming in on
when we start off you but how do you how
do you believe inside did you do you
know Jay have you ever met him before
Cameron at all uh I've met him with you
Tom gum usually it's in the heat of
battle and you know I was playing a boom
on him a couple of times and I obviously
reminded him of that in the last few
days chasing around on the field but um
I hadn't met him personally though okay
so first of all how did Jay take that
good-natured if you will ribbing maker
get in charge it's going to shaadi uh
you know he's always talked smack back
and forth off in his defense and you
know you had couple treats choice words
for our DB you know about how he was
going to perform in the next few weeks
so it it it's always a good fun it ought
to be competition it's the way you want
it to be we wanted to make whether it's
him or any other quarterback or
offensive line and that's where we set
it up that we're going to make it as
hard as possible we won't put you in the
worst situation and practice with the
hopefully the best defensive ends
chasing you all over the field so that
on Sunday you know hopefully you've seen
it before you've done it before and you
know how to attack it and be successful
with it when it really counts so you're
saying Cameron Wake here in the Rich
Eisen show from the Dolphins you're
saying Jay Cutler already feels
comfortable enough to start whooping
back at members of your defensive squad
well I mean he's not he's not his first
go-round I mean he's got to be done this
for a while you see the quarterback has
played a lot of plays and Italy and if
you're a corner and you are gonna stop
trash to a quarterback and he's gonna
talk back out to me I bet make me feel
good I want you to be confident say
listen you can't intercept this ball
you're not going to be able to affect me
and as a defensive end or
the back I want you I'm in a corner back
I want you to have the same confidence
that whatever ball you throw I'm going
to take and anytime you step on the
field you better look out for me to hit
you so if that's the way footballs
building that's why I love this game is
because there's no there's no in between
it's pass/fail you got the job done you
didn't both men say they can do a job
only ones going to walk off victorious
and that's uh that's what you want to
how is change are you doing as you can
tell
oh far as I know you got a lot okay and
for this team what goals are you openly
discussing Cameron Oh improvement I
think you know obviously it's one of the
main reasons I've found what I've way
back when I'm signed of Miami Dolphins
was because of the franchise as a whole
as a winning franchise it's the
franchise when you think of it always
been on top you know we always have you
know fan appreciation days and they come
and they talk about you know how from
the time they were how young kids or
whatever stand that this franchise is
one that's always been successful and
just doing whatever I can to help with
you know this franchise back on that in
that place back where belong you know
building on the success we had last year
and I think for the most part guys who
were here understood what it took to get
to that level and that even that level
we got you just get into the twelve was
it enough that they are if you you know
how to do so much to get there now it's
going to take even more to go even
further and and get you know to our
ultimate goal so I think improvement is
our main focus whether it's individually
you know or as a unit or the team you
know making sure that you know we do
better and be more consistent and so on
and so forth so that to me is the
purpose of training camp and that is a
norm angle and I'm a focus of the team a
couple of more minutes left with Cameron
wake of the Miami Dolphins here on the
Rich Eisen show you just mentioned
earlier that you were working stiffs put
on a suit and tie nine to five day job
you're a man of the world you've been
there and done that football on and off
the field Mike Freeman of the belief
reports saying that he spoken to several
players over the weekend about what
happened in Charlottesville Virginia and
how there might be more
we've already seen Michael Bennett sit
down we've already seen Marshawn Lynch
sit down during the national anthem are
you and the Dolphins having a
conversation with in the locker room
about events outside of it Cameron oh
well we we definitely speak about a lot
of things going on in the world and
that's you know current events something
that's come up and you know this the
reality is you know we all live in you
know United States American there's so
much going on and so much that affects
not only us you know firstly but our
families and friends and loved ones and
there are so many things and so many
times for us you know the season or you
can talk to you that things happen that
are bigger than football as they say you
know we obviously play a game and for
the style of planet Earth here so it's
what I think most guys know that you
know there's a big picture out there and
there's things that need to be addressed
and things that are going on that I
think surpass a game you know playing a
football game and I think things that
are going on are people charlatan you
want to talk to excuse me and one of
them where it is something that is hard
to ignore and you know I think it's not
something that you know we have the self
esteem or families you know something
that's that's fun to set here so it is
special it was proven about sure all
right before I let you go
Cameron how concerned should I be about
the Wolverines walking into Penn State
middle this Big Ten season how concerned
should I be as a Wolverine ah you know
that's just speaking about this
Wolverine makes me a little nauseous but
snow boy you know over the past few
years I look at this scene the Penn
State football I'm speaking about and it
seems like it's getting better and
better and obviously I think you should
be very nervous in a being a Wolverine
okay we'll be back all right you want to
put a number on it a scale of 1 to 10
how concerned are concerned I think 12 a
beginner oh my gosh
I don't even know that's that usually I
might go to 11 but not 12 all right so
can we put a pin in this conversation
and revisit it maybe sometime in October
what do you think I think that's there
okay okay all right and I just want to
make sure that whatever is going on in
the
FL season for you in the Dolphins you're
still going to make time for my phone
call okay I got okay Cameron I always
appreciate you calling it thanks so much
good luck the rest of the preseason and
certainly week one and beyond I
appreciate that you bet that's Cameron
wake of the Miami Dolphins here on the
Rajasa the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
some of that get some more of that on
the Rich Eisen shell app follow all the
information you see right here on the
Rich Eisen show